it's all good we're winging it
the boys are gonna flip you feel amazing
i had a crazy idea but it might just
work
i don't even know why i try hi i'm
hannah i'm the world's okay
mom and i am tired i'm here with my kids
every single day i'm cooking three meals
a day right now and i'm feeling very
uninspired when it comes to
meal planning i do most of my grocery
shopping online
and it's just really hard to think of
new and improved ideas for meals so i'm
gonna try something for this week i'm
gonna let
my kids do the grocery shopping i'm
hoping i get some inspiration
wish me luck up first the rules one
i'm not going over budget for this week
the kids are limited
to the budget that i usually spend on
groceries second it can't all be junk
food there has to be some semblance of
health we've done the junk food week
we're not going to do it again three we
can't eat the same thing every night we
have to have some variety we can't just
have chicken fingers for dinner every
single night the whole point is to come
up with some new meals that we can try
together as a family and last i have
full access to my pantry refrigerator
and freezer guess what you get to do
this week don't ain't
don't sit in the baby seat
you get to do all of our grocery
shopping for the week
and then i'm gonna have to figure out
what to cook so because we're trying to
self isolate as well as we can we do
grocery delivery so it was really easy
for the boys to be able
to scroll through all of the aisles on
the app and choose whatever they wanted
for groceries
oh yes peppers
i was very nervous when they were
scrolling through the app because i know
that
they don't know what a lot of the foods
are and so they'll see one word and
think it needs another thing and maybe
put that in the cart
no you feel like you got a good list
yeah okay should i check out
yeah okay well we came in under budget
that's good i'm not going to look
too deep into this list because i want
to be a little bit surprised but good
job
and the next morning the groceries
arrived
[Music]
i see some normal stuff this is good
they ordered a lot of meat
and they were clearly confused about
what a couple of the ingredients
actually were i saw jalapeno peppers in
there
i know that they thought they were bell
peppers i was pleasantly surprised by
the lack of junk food in there honestly
i'm very proud of them for making good
food choices
lots of salad lots of greens and
that is all i could ask for as a parent
good morning
i am starting the day making dinner
because it's in the slow cooker
in the groceries i noticed there was a
big cut of chuck roast
there was also a packet of ranch
seasoning in with this grocery haul so i
knew the boys wanted me to make
mississippi roast which is a super easy
and really delicious recipe
i usually get pepperoncinis but they
didn't get any so all i have is banana
peppers so i'm going to try it
it might be like pretty salty i'm going
to cover this
cook it on low for 9 hours i don't cook
a lot of red meat and i don't cook
mississippi roast very often
because it is pretty high in fat but it
is really good so i don't blame the boys
for choosing it
it's been in here for nine hours and
then it just pulls apart
this is how i typically serve it just
cut some bread soaks up all those juices
and then i'm serving this alongside one
of their bagged salads that they chose
how does this look to you wyatt
yum does it taste like i usually make it
that's good what do you think wyatt
that meal was a huge success it reminded
me honestly
to utilize my slow cooker in the morning
and by dinner time everything is ready
and i don't even have to prepare
food this is good it's a little less
spicy and it's very very delicious for
how easy it is to make
this is a good one day one successful
easy and i was ready to dive into day
two
on day two i wanted to get one weird
ingredient out of the way
popcorn i have to figure out how to
incorporate this into a dinner lately
we've been doing movie nights every week
and we've been doing popcorn every night
that we have movie night so i think the
boys figured if they got a lot of
popcorn
we would have movie nights all week
which is not how that works but nice try
were you thinking of something when you
put the popcorn in the basket
i was thinking about eating it just
plain
but how could we use popcorn in a meal
on toast popcorn toast you put butter on
your toast
and you put the popcorn on and popcorn
is good with butter
do you know i did that when i was your
age i think like you
i know i think i have a picture of it i
guess weird people raise weird kids okay
i think i figured it out i'm gonna do
a chicken tortilla soup and when i
typically crash chips on top i'm gonna
offer popcorn
as a topping then on the side i will
also have toast with butter and popcorn
and really make it a popcorn
popcorn-centric meal
can you help me out by popping the
popcorn
that's how you open a box all right
let's check on
let's check on the soup i used a pot
that is far too small but it looks
decent
okay it's like melting when you put it
in the soup
do you like it it gives it some crunch
that's surprisingly good
cosmos bottle um maybe i should have
gotten you a plate
so day two was a little weird but little
did i know that the weirdest was yet to
come
day three i really wanted to do
something visually splashy
one grocery that's plentiful in this
hall
is fruit
so i'm going to try a breakfast for
dinner
style meal and i'm going to make a
fruit parfait platter and i'm going to
do some baked apple oatmeal
because that's always easy and i think
the kids will like it i do
oatmeal cinnamon nutmeg salt
eggs almond milk baking powder and it's
like a batter so i got my honeycomb
apples you're supposed to skin your
apples but i don't feel like it very
excited about this oatmeal bacon to
assemble
so i have some plain greek yogurt let's
drizzle
a little honey on top i'm going to do
some kiwi
i had this vision of like the most
beautiful
colorful platter and i feel like it came
close
but it wasn't quite as splashy as i'd
expected that doesn't
oh really no it's part of dinner this
dinner yeah that's fair what do you
think
i think it looks delicious too sour
try it with the fruit you're supposed to
eat it with the fruit honey
i've not seen you guys this excited to
have dinner in a very long time
what does henry think day three overall
was
not the most traditional but that's how
we roll in our family so
it was great success check that off the
box on to day four
day four i decided to tackle the most
difficult ingredient of the week
jalapenos i honestly am so tired tonight
i don't feel like cooking
i don't feel like dealing with jalapenos
but it's
better to just get it over with we have
a plan i stuff these with cream cheese
and shredded cheese
and i'm going to try to make jalapeno
popper stuffed
chicken so this is ready to be
butterflied jackson is mixing some eggs
wyatt's going to get the panko in a bowl
right
okay what's a panko it's breadcrumbs
it's black yeah okay look at that
that looks decent moment
truth for this chicken
that's something so jackson says he
likes spicy food but
in his mind spicy food is mild salsa
from taco bell
wyatt on the other hand does eat pretty
spicy food and doesn't really flinch
this is
not spicy yeah it's not it's not
inspired by a single bit
he's amazing am i crushing it at this
point
75 i'd say there's always room for
improvement stay humble
but i was very proud of that day i'm
very grateful that day four was as easy
as it was
because little did i know i was about to
lose my
mind i don't even want to talk about day
five day five
was a day day five was
challenging day five freaking sucked
we have a slight problem with tonight's
meal
i decided to tackle the whole roasted
chicken
here's the thing it's 6.50 this chicken
roasts for an hour and a half and these
potatoes cook for 55 minutes
so there's my chicken roasting
my house smells delicious but but this
thing
is going to take you know another hour
and 20 minutes
i have my potatoes soaking
and i'm gonna do those in a cast iron
it's fine i've lost my mind my kids are
already hungry
i don't know what i'm gonna do because
the food's gonna be finished at 8 30
at the earliest they go to bed
at 8 30 so i'm about to cover this up
i'm going to put another pan on top of
it
[Music]
this isn't a meal that you make on a
week night for your family this is a
meal you make on a saturday for a dinner
party and you definitely don't start
cooking it
at almost seven o'clock oh
i'm gonna have to order dinner i made
the space for the chicken and the
potatoes i got them both in
they were cooking nicely but then it was
henry's bedtime and i had to put him to
bed
i did not set myself a timer there's so
much i could have done to prevent what
happened and i just didn't do it
did i over cook it yes is it completely
charred and stuck to the bottom
also yes i did not take my time with
this one
and make sure that the potatoes were
completely dry so i don't know what that
did but i think it ruined it
why did i do that i was not ready to
throw in the towel i was not ready to
give up on those potatoes and so
i came up with the only solution i could
think of it's not
charred if you cover it with cheese
that's our new family motto it's not
charred if you cover it with cheese
i got carried away i thought i was on a
roll
i am an excellent cook i'm pulling these
foods off that i didn't think were
possible
i am in a garden today is not my day
let's
try a potato
they're good it's just not worth it
chicken is tasty
never again what do you think
[Music]
it's good potatoes are a little
don't even the potatoes are a little wet
tasty a little too good for your palette
it took like three hours like this i
know
it really did after day five i was kind
of ready to quit i didn't want to try
anymore
so day six i went easy on myself here's
my plan
the kids got pasta i'm gonna make two
bags of this because
you know leftovers that's how i roll
they did not get me pasta sauce though
they got me petite diced tomatoes
several cans of this the boys are
usually really good at observing in the
kitchen and i feel that overall
their grocery shopping instincts were
good but in this case to them
pasta sauce and tomatoes are the same
thing so i'm gonna have to turn this
into
tomato sauce into a pasta sauce without
proper ingredients that i usually use to
make like a bolognese or
i want some saltine crackles you want
saltine crackers
is that what you'd like for dinner i
don't even know why i try
there are some really core pieces to
pasta sauce that make it really good one
is adding some pasta water into it
and one is making sure that it's
seasoned really well and then it has
time to simmer
i'm not saying this is authentic italian
pasta sauce i'm saying this is
my pasta sauce well we made something
what do you think jackson
it looks yummy how's the pasta sauce huh
you like it good
that's amazing it was good the pasta
turned out delicious
day six was an easy win which was good
because i had a crazy idea for day seven
by day seven i only had random
ingredients left but i had an idea
this complete
taco dinner kit naturally i was gonna do
spaghetti tacos because that's just
what we always do but i realized i used
the pasta
on the night that i was going easy on
myself so
what i have left from the grocery haul
that jackson hand picked
is mac and cheese i'm gonna try to do a
mac and cheese
taco party let's see how this works with
the
taco sauce seasoning let's mix this
up we'll give it a little taste
oh that's good it's not too salty i
thought it would be kind of salty
it might just work voila
mac and cheese taco night
how is it is this the next spaghetti
taco
yeah there's mac and cheese in the taco
this is the epitome of having a picky
eater wyatt chose all the ingredients
they're all foods that he liked
separately but together he wasn't
willing to try it at first
it takes a little coaxing it takes a
little encouragement
[Music]
it's good it's good
do you like it it's really good
it's weird but good you know like the
thought of it is weird but the taste of
it is really good
our mac and cheese tacos the thing heck
yes they are
it's the new and improved version and
i'm here for it
at the end of the week i was very proud
of my kids grocery choices there were
healthy options in there
so i consider that a mom win but what i
did learn
is there are some meals that i had
forgotten about that i can continue to
make
the slow cooker meal made my life really
easy and there are just
fun ways that we can shake things up
moving forward
to make meal time more fun so that's all
i got for today i'm hannah and i want to
know would you try this with your family
would you try any of the recipes i made
and most importantly would you eat a mac
and cheese taco party
let me know on instagram and if you'll
please excuse me
i'm gonna go order take out for dinner
tonight till next time
[Music]
you